[音楽]
皆さんデロリアンという車をご存知でしょうか
映画バックトゥザフューチャーでタイマー神として使われこんな風に扉が上に楽
かっこいい車ですえ
これが私の愛車です
実はこの車 ev 電気自動車なんです
デロリアン電気自動車なんで売ってたのっていうことなんですけども実はそうじゃない
んですこれ私たち自分たちで作ったんです
これあの製造から36年くらい経って車なんですけれども
まあその電気同社ということなんでエコカー減税対象車なんです
だかそんな面白いことができちゃいました
私自身この黒がと出合ったのがやはり映画でした
未来が過去あの時もあるカッコイイデロリアに魅せられて
いいなこの黒みつか乗ってみたいができれば私も欲しいなと思ったこともあります
はですねあのオリジナルのデロリアンものすごく壊れやすくてなんか維持するのは大変
なんですね
でまぁ元々そんなにあのそこらへんにある車じゃないんで
まあ夢だなと思ってそれ切り
回ったんですけれども通常この話はここで終わったりします
私あの環境問題に興味がありましてですね
ルールを調べているうちに電気自動車っていうあの分野に
を知ることになりました
電気同社あの co2削減にとても有効な手段だということがわかったんです
まぁざっ電車からあの電気上司に乗り換えるっていうことですね
んあなるほど環境問題そういう光景あるんだと思ってもう一つ
ev て実はとてもあの構造が簡単でもあの壊れにくいっていう特徴があることが理由
ありましたその時にフッと気がついたんですがまぁひらめいたんです
下呂慰安を電気自動車にしてしまいが壊れないデルレイができるじゃないかと
これ面白いと思ったんですねでさらにあの映画の中で毒が自慢げに
た居場所をつくった時に言った台詞を思い出しました
どうせ作るんだったらかっこいいほうがいいじゃないか
よしじゃあ私もこのプロジェクトやってみようっていうことでたった一人で始めたん
です
そしたらいろんな中のが集まってきましてねなんかとても楽しいケーキができたなぁと
思ってます
でっ
こちら2015年10月21日
a これが何の日かわかりでしょうか
バックトゥザフューチャー part 2というのは1989年の公開なんですけれど
も
相続にデロリアンが飛んでった未来の都市が2015年の10月21日だったんです
でこの日8
に飛んでったデロリアンって実はここに置いてあるようにですね
ビールとまだなのかはで
走ってましたまあそれであの未来からですねあの飛んできたというのが描かれてたん
ですけれども
まあこれが未来ですねで8私達とその未来の日なんか面白いことやろうということで
ポケモンゴーみたいなイベントをちょっとやったんです友人にですね
twitter に自動はあの位置情報を自動配信するアプリというのを作ってもらい
まして
それを持ってですねデロリアンで広島市内あちこち走り回るんです
をしたらですねあのまあ未来の日にベロリアに会えるということで何かとても
あの面白がってくれましてですね色んな人がその
僕が今走ってるところに集まってくれてデロリアを囲んで未来の日が来たねすごいでっ
ていうのを
外は行ったんです
であの今日ですよね痩せる各社共ですよねっていう風に言ってえらい
あの張り切ったり動画ですねあの盛り上がっている必要がありたりとか
だからとてもすごい面白い経験ができました
でですねそのときにいろんな人があのこんなこと言うんです
a子のデロリアすごいですね電気で走るんですか
でも
この車なのゴミだしたらもっとすごいね
って言うんです電気で走るだけでも結構大変だとにそこまで言うかっていう気持ちが
あったんですけど
じゃあ実際にやってみましょうかということで実はこういうゴミで走る ev
デロリアンっていう企画を実際に行ってみて皆の前で走って見せました
これは生ごみをですね発行
させるとアンモニアとかですねメタンガスができますそこから月は水素って作れるん
ですね
でその水素を使って発電したらですねえぇまぁ電気で行くのででそれを充電すれば ev
デロリアンというのはまあもう
劇場者になってますから
なんと生ごみのエネルギーで走ることができるのです
れしかもこれゼロエミッションあんです
どうですこの無理くり館
here till 皆の
第0スイスエンジンで発電して充電してどうラーっていうのを見せ見せました
薄磯エンジンっていうのはもう出るのは排気ガスじゃなくての垂直しか出ないんで全然
臭くないんですね
フェイス磯で動く園児ってこんなんだっていうのをみんなに見てもらったりして皆で
未来の体験を一緒にしたっ
いることになりましたで私たちの活動で
デューサーの電気自動車というのはとてもあのイノベーションの塊だっていうことが
よくわかりました
で再来んですね8モーターとか全治とかですね
今ものすごく技術がどんどん進んでいるのでもしかしたら詰め替えたら
なの性能がどんどんアップできるんです
この車もそうなんですけど時差の
これまで3回アップグレードしましたので走行距離も50キロから100ロリーとか
ですね急速充電が使えるようになったとか
どんどんできた後もこの進化してるんですけれども今ここに写っている
電磁これ今だいたい120キロぐらい走る電池なんですけど
現地がもっともっと良くなればこの車の状態で317 k 走ろうとまたできる時代が
ままなくるような感じがしてますそういうイノベーションをとても感じることができ
たい
なんかむしろがたなと思ってます
さて
2011年3月11日この日何が起こったかみなさんもちろんお分かりだと思います
東日本大震災津波
日原発のメルトダウン
過酷な放射線被害や故郷はれる人たちの理不尽さを目の当たりにしてエネルギーを真剣
に考える日になりました
私も考え方が変わりました
科学技術の在り方を根本的に変えなくちゃいけないんじゃないかという思いです
やはりあの i 量生産大量消費の社会はもう駄目ですねそうではなく
まあエネルギーもそうですね a fire の豊かさの象徴なんですエネルギーと
いうのはそれを足りないから環境負荷高めて二発電を増やすというのではなく効率を
上げる
a まだ
十分にうまく使えていない再生可能エネルギーをうまく使うそういった姿勢がやっぱり
求められていると思うんです
で目標にしたいのですね世界一エコロジカルの年だった江戸
だと思いますやはりそういうふうなですね持続可能な社会に向けて私たちの彼らしい
ほとんど変えていかないといけないんじゃないかなというふうに思います
実はその時ずっと浮かぶのがエロリアンは最初プルトニウムから走ったんですけどそれ
が
これに変わりました
やっぱプルトニウムからあの花が可愛いと進化したように夜中どんどん変わっていけ
たらいいなと思ってます
私実はですねあのこんなあの壮大な夢を持ってはいるんですけれども
あのその夢を尖って実現しているが実際よくわからないんです
なぜかと言いますとえっとここで一つちょっとあの拍手をしますけど私実はコテコテの
文系なんです
形にするスキルと思ってないんですよそれを実現させてくれたのがこの出るリアの ev
化計画というブログでした
この場を使ってですね発動の4種とか今こんなことやってる
でもここで困ってる
わかんないここっていうのをどんどん情報を発信しながらメンバー募集してました
そしたらマツダの ob の方とかあの電気配線の専門が大学院生などそういう
いろんなスキルのある人たち面白そうだって集まってくれました8ネット上で情報を
寄せてくれる人も出始めまして
うわぁぁ
これってあのまあ
まあホントそういう人たちと集まりながらいろいろやっててですね
情報っていうのは発信する所のところに集まるんだということがよくわかりました
まあこの方は真っ青 b の蛭田さんっていうことなんですけどあの2年前に卵では
なくなりになりました
とても物静かな紳士だったんですけれども現役時代あの電気自動車の開発に駆動系で
かかってらっしゃいましたじゃあ実際その研究をしているときにですねこれはその城
イノベーションだというふうに技術者としてお金
あったんですけども実証実験ではてしまってとても何かやり残した感があったようです
で後に私のプロジェクトを知って手伝ってくれるようになりました
2回目のアップグレードの時には入社府の病院から来てくれたこともありました
a
まああの子の仕事なんか最後のうちことというふうに思ってくれたようです何かとても
感謝の気持ちいっぱいなんです
さらに遡るとですねあのベース車の入手からとても良いご縁がありました
私このプロジェクト始めるにあたって税者はもう捨てられそうなデロリアンがあったら
始めようというふうに決めてました
2年間で8000台しか生産されなかった希少な車なんで
普通に走るデロリアをわざわざ改造しする
うっていうのはやりたくなかったんです
出そう
うこれはないかなぁと思ってネット色々探してたらですね東京の佐野さんっていう方が
事故に遭われて全損で廃車になったデロリアンっていうのを待っ部品取り状態で売りに
出されてたんですねえ私も出てきたと思ってすぐ先方に連絡してこれって簡単に直せ
ない車ですよねっていうのを
33聞いてたら
先方からこんなことを言われましたあの他でもいろんな人から問い合わせ
あるんだけど皆さんこの車ってどうやったら直せるのか直そうにいくらかかるのかって
いう風に聞いてくるんだ
でも当たってまったく逆のことを聞いてくる一体何やろうとしてんだ
で私はあのデロリアンを ev からしてですねあの子世帯に残せる
車にしたいんだという夢は正直に話しました
そしたら
なんだか面白そうなことやるんだねよしわかったじゃあ
この車は挿絵られますから行ってくださいよということです
私でロリーはパターでもらったんです
さあその佐野さんがですねえさ cg クリエイターで
ルーカスフィルムというところでも仕事をした経験がある方ですっでまあ要はですね
道路の中にバックトゥザフューチャーの良いスタッフのいたあーかてぃですねでなんか
そんな方から夢託されたらもう絶対なきゃいけないよねっていうことで
まーひー
になってやりましてまあそういった形でですねまぁいろんなあの方とのである
いろんな時間軸の中でですねこのプロジェクトを進めまして
なんとかできましたで車検を通した日が2009年の3月11日ちょうど震災の2年前
だったんです
であの完成していこうですねあのいろんな人がですね
私もこんなことを考えてたんだっていう言い方を牛に来られる方がたくさんいました
でもプロジェクトが実際に形になる前は
あのとても否定的な意見を言われる方が多くよかったですね
テスラのあの ceo の
色マスクさんがあのこんなことを実は言われてたんですけれども
なんであのチェイサーさんはそんなに速く電気自動車って作れたんですかって聞かれた
ときに
アイデアって思いつくよりも実際に形にする方が全然難しいだろうっていうのを堪えさ
そうです
で私もやっぱりそうだと思います
アイディアって考えただけでは実は何もやってないと話しなんじゃないかっていうふう
にへ
感じました
え私の場合もあのじっくり考えてまずできるところから形にしていきました
なのであのができるところからやったのでまあその後アップグレードしたんですけれど
も
ああ
そうすることによっている具体的になりますし
えっと課題も見えてくるしで周りのソニア
こんなことがやりたかったをねあなたはっていうのが分かってもらえる
それもそんな機会になったと思います
前記同社をデロリアンでやってよかったなと思うのはあの
見に来てくれた方がですねとても未来を語ってくれるんです
それが大好きだったんです
普通の車で電気当社をつくってみたとします
電気自動車に興味がある人は来てくれるけれどもそうじゃない人とはなかなか出会え
ないですね
でもう一つとても性能は良いガソリン車がありますからそれといいぶー並べると走行
距離が短いよねとかそういったデメリットがすごい際立ちます
でもエロリアの場合はライバルがプルトニウム火山パンです
このプルがお前にですねでまだな不十分だけどあの未来につながる
あのストーリーをですねあの提示してみると皆さんはものすごく楽しそうに自由に未来
を語ってくれます
まあこの笑顔を見ているとですねさあ次は何を始めようか
っていう気になってきますまあそれが私の原動力です
まあそんな風にですね10年間でロリアンと一緒に ev の世界を見続けてきました
これから先どんな未来が待ってるんでしょうか
そしてどんな未来を創っていきましょうかね
8未来ってなんかね自分で作れると思うんです
皆さんともぜひ一緒に作っていきたいなと思っています
ぜひ一緒に作ってみましょう
それでは次はあの ev デロリアンがさらに飛べるようになった頃にお会いし
ましょう
どうもご静聴ありがとうございました
分
[音楽]
[拍手]